hi everyone I'm Deborah tgn a human
woman it's very nice to see you I'm old
though I got at I'm getting old I can't
legally tell you how old I am in Los
Angeles because they will chase me out
of the city
there's snow with a sharpened stick over
30 burn her but here's the thing I'm
very lucky cuz I look younger than I am
like if I was to tell you my real age
you would all panic you back whatever
stop
you look so young that's what you would
say but here's the thing the only reason
I look young is because I'm fat that is
the only reason it fills in the lines
are you kidding me oh you idiots wasting
money on Botox this is cheese you
understand look at it wait
8:19 out of bloc dum-dums look at this
face are you kidding
it's true Beck I get it Jovie I'm gonna
die soon but I'm gonna look good I'm
gonna look good did she die is the baby
the last was she a baby when she died
makes it a better story anyway I was
outside for a minute today just a minute
cuz it's terrifying out there but I got
catcalled right away
I got catcalled yeah it was real cats
though I'm not gonna lie I was replayed
for a bit it was fun but here's the
thing cats aren't stupid they know I'm
the leader gentlemen they're like let's
follow the big one she's covered with
crumbs but I'll tell you this right now
I know we have trouble in the world
women getting sexually harassed being
catcalled in the street I don't want
that I want everyone to feel safe and
equal every AM every moment of your life
all right but listen to me right now
when I say this the day that cat calling
ends oh that's a cold day my friends
that's a cold day you walk by a group of
men and it's silent it hurts your heart
I'm not gonna lie I would do anything to
be demeaned right now Genevieve
just I just want this I just want this
is he following me don't lie to me fear
is hot don't lie to me are you kidding
it gets your blood up then he's gonna
chase me
it's cardio to get your knees up but
here's the thing I will do this I do
like to be scared I'm one of those
weirdos
I enjoy being frightened I love horror
movies I love shows about murder but I
realized that it's starting to get my
brain cuckoo gentlemen like now I will
turn a regular incident into like a
horror movie like okay going for dinner
with friends it's a little later so at
like 5 o'clock I'm like I need a little
snack so I have a scoop of peanut butter
let's live our lives let's have some
peanut butter germs say would you ever
do this do you ever opened a jar of
peanut butter and panic because you
don't recognize the tracks in the peanut
butter jar do that
I don't remember that scoop that scope
and you panic because you assume someone
has broken into your house and they're
gonna murder you that's what I would do
if I was gonna murder someone I'd have
some peanut butter do I say a little
protein okay these are just ideas I'm
not a doctor but I'll say this
another thing that terrifies me people
that sleep naked Oh who's thinks a good
read of applause you say maggot you're a
hero
you're a champion to me if you sleep
naked anything can happen in the middle
of the night to anything at all no I do
not sleep naked and one number one I'll
tell you that
you're welcome feel free to drop by but
number two everyone the reason I don't
sleep naked is because I'm scared
something is gonna crawl into me now
listen to me on this you got a list of
me as I watch a lot of horror movies and
then I fought with pornography right
after
that is the terrible combination you
don't get eight hours after that there's
no good night night Terrace that's all
there is
I also tell you this pornography is very
scary now I don't know if you know this
children but in the old days pornography
used to be very nice to remember when
someone who's a feather as a tool of
seduction a feather feather
you remember come and be like time to
get sexy with my woman and he would get
a feather out I don't know where he
found it on the grounds maybe out of his
pocket perhaps like a damp feather oh
let me tell you this right now you come
at me with a feather I'm gonna knock you
down I'm gonna knock the job I'm horny
I'm not dusty let's do this anyway I
could use the cleaning please don't look
at me here's something else but I'll
tell you know I know the world is very
precious right now we offend very
quickly I had a woman come up to me
after a show and she was like excuse me
you cannot use the word [ __ ] and I was
like whatever slide but I didn't say
that and I actually I don't even use the
word [ __ ] in my life but here's the
thing I could because there's an old
rule in comedy that says I'm allowed to
tell jokes about [ __ ] because one of my
sister's is a [ __ ] so I don't you think
that's not nice but I have three sisters
so you don't know which what I'm talking
about yeah unless you know my family
then you totally know who I'm talking
about
it is Monica anyway
that said everyone thank you so much
you